he's Chris Sims the pro football talk
live co-host on NBC Sports Network also
with bleacher report he joins me here on
the on the Dan Patrick show Chris your
thoughts on esports any any thoughts
there well yeah I got thoughts I mean I
got a 12 year old and a 8 year old so I
mean you know between fortnight and then
sitting there in front of the TV and
watching youtube videos of other people
playing video games yeah it's crazy I
mean it's taken over the world I gotta
set rules and regulations on my kids
because I'm sitting there going they're
literally watching these videos getting
dumber as I watch them so yeah I try to
limit it a little bit for tonight
certainly made my little boy crazy this
summer from overplaying that I
understand I love video games I played
them when I was younger too I don't
anymore but I am amazed that kids watch
other people play video games now right
now and that is a thing and it's
extremely lucrative at this point that's
the most bizarre one of them all because
growing up but even now I don't I get
pissed off when I have to wait to play
video games I don't want to watch
somebody in the same room with me play
here yeah my kids watch ninja and you
know the other day my little boy was
trying to say hey Dad Ninja makes as
much money as LeBron James and I was
like no there's no way that's possible
but I looked it up and damn ninjas
making like 25 million dollars a year so
I didn't realize it was that that kind
of money in that business there's money
in it but for the people that don't make
it don't know what is it it's it's just
we're talking to Chris Simmons a pro
football talk live NBC football night in
America bleacher report NFL analyst of
the wildcard weekend quarterbacks which
quarterback do you have the least
confidence in oh that is a very good
question okay well I think that
conversation comes down to two people
for me that would be Lamar Jackson and
Mitchell true Biscay between one of
those two you know and I would really
probably say you know gosh that's a
tough one just because the thing I don't
have confidence in their consistency in
the passing game yet to where I got a
seat a little bit to believe it here in
the wild-card weekend the playoffs
whatever it may be
that
are going to be able to consistently
execute third and five or third and
eight situations against playoff
defenses who have done deep dive
scouting and they're going to be able to
put the money put the ball on the money
and make the right decisions now at the
same time both of those guys in those
situations can escape the pocket and run
for 30 yards to that's where it makes
them dangerous but I do worry in playoff
football where things become a little
harder the scouting becomes a little
more in-depth that yes there can be some
indecisiveness and decision-making and
maybe some erratic throws from those two
more than than any of the others in the
end the playoffs if Nick Foles beats the
Bears no matter what happens the carson
wentz health-wise this season does he
deserve to be the quarterback the rest
of the way yes he does
hands down yes I believe that even last
week once they won the game if Carson
Wentz was a hundred percent ready to go
you ride with the hot hand here and I'll
say this to just clarify Carson Wentz is
clearly a more talented player than Nick
Foles but Nick Foles has played
phenomenal the last few weeks and I will
say they played some teams that they
match up with very well with and we you
and I know that it's a matchup sport but
the team is rally around it - its
unified them and the Eagles have changed
their style of play I've even said I'm
Pro Football Talk it's annoyed me a
little bit about Philadelphia where
they've got into more of the style of
how they played last year which was
running in between the tackles some
quick throws an occasional shot down the
down the field they got away with that
with Carson Wentz it got too enamored
with him just standing in a pocket
trying to dissect people and throwing
lasers all over the field and they
didn't play to their strengths but yeah
I'm with you at least I think I'm with
you there if they win this weekend you
ride with Nick Foles until it's over I
think Nick Foles
and what the Eagles do is one of the
more interesting storylines of this
entire postseason I mean he caught
lightning in a bottle last year took
them to a Super Bowl graciously you know
it took some more money but Grace Lee
accepted a backup role now here he is
coming in again winning games at the end
of the regular season if Nick Foles
catches fires again let's say Chris they
get to the NFC championship game or
beyond I mean what do those do
at that point long-term that is like the
million dollar question and you add to
this conversation to me like I look at
the Chicago Bears as being very similar
to last year's Philadelphia Eagles team
like nobody's really quite respecting
them I think there's a second best team
in the NSC they can cause I got a great
defense pass rushers people are doubting
the quarterback just like they were
doubting Nick Foles last year in the
playoffs but yeah the Eagles are gonna
be in a true problem there and I don't
know what they do at this point I would
ride with Carson Wentz if even if things
happen this year because I do think the
end game Carson Wentz is the more
talented football player
he's young in his career and I guess the
other thing I would say is they have
they they've invested a lot to get
Carson Wentz so I guess those are the
angles I would play there I do think
Nick Foles is a good quarterback he is
certainly going to be a starting
quarterback somewhere next year I would
imagine but I don't think his talent
level or his ceiling is nearly as high
as a Carson Wentz let's not forget
Carson Wentz was clearly going to be the
MVP last year in the NFL when he got
hurt in week 14 I mean I thought it was
his to lose I can remember in the Rams
game where he hurt his knee how he long
coming out on a half-time because it was
a fox game going I'm watching John Elway
out here and it just tells you how crazy
the NFL is one injury one thing happens
and it can just totally flip your world
around
I had a Chris Sims pro football talk
live bleacher report NFL joining me here
on the Dan Patrick show so it since 1970
Chris only 10 teams during the white in
this wild card format have advanced the
Super Bowl if you had to bet on one out
of this crop to make the Super Bowl
would you say I would probably go I
would probably go with the Chargers I
think that would be the team I would
look at I'm going to pick the Chargers
to beat the Ravens this weekend and a
close one the NFC is wide open so that's
how I look at it where I just go listen
I think any of the AFC teams the Colts
they match up with certain teams really
well - I wouldn't be shocked if they
were there but I look at the Chargers as
one of the teams in the AFC with the
least amount of weaknesses pretty good
offensive line great pass rushers great
team speed and secondary on their
defense they got weapons galore on the
offensive side I would argue that just
out of pure
receiver's it's the best wide receiver
group there is in the NFL you know when
you got Mike Williams Tyrell Williams
Kelvin Benjamin and Who am I missing I'm
missing one more Keenan Allen sorry
there they are a tough team to match up
with and then of course it's Philip
Rivers and they can run the ball so I
would look at the Chargers to be that
one team to make a run now I'm with you
on the Chargers I actually think Dallas
is in that year I mean the the running
game the defense I also think though
Chris if they wind up losing to the
Seahawks and if they lose by double
digits even yeah you got to put Jason
Garrett on the first bus on a town you
just have to at that point I would
imagine that would be the case I would
be shocked if they lost the Seattle I'll
say that much but I'm with you I look at
the Cowboys and the Bears as teams now I
understand the Saints are clearly the
best team in the NFC and the best team
in the NFL but the Saints and I mean
excuse me the Cowboys and bears have
some elite things about their football
team that as we saw on a Thursday night
when the Saints played the Cowboys that
can change the flow of a game even
against a great team like the Saints the
Cowboys and Bears defenses our Super
Bowl caliber type defenses where one
strip sack fumble or one pick six and
all of a sudden there's a game they're
an underdog in and you're going whoa
they're gonna pull off the upset here so
I look at two of them as being dangerous
as we go forward for sure Chris always
great to talk to you man keep up the
great work thanks for the time thanks
Chris be good man have a good weekend
that's Chris Simms Pro Football Talk
live co-host bleacher report NFL joining
me here on the Dan Patrick show for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]